Speaker 1: And. Here's another issue. We talk
about Marjorie Taylor GREENE, we talk about
Lauren Boebert, you know, your Matt Gaetz as
your Jim Jordans, all of these little extremists
out there serving in Congress today. They're
dangerous individuals and they're individuals
who after this year's midterms. Might have
even more power, which is even scarier.
But right now. According to a report from
The New Republic. You have Democratic groups,
including, by the way, Nancy Pelosi's
majority political action committee
that are actually out there in this country
running ads. Trying to promote extremist
Republican candidates because they somehow
think that if we promote the extremist and
then they get on the primary or they make it
past the primary, get on the general ballot,
then, hey, that's going to drive people to the
Democrats, right? Because that worked so well in
2016 when when the Democratic Party promoted Trump
because they thought he'd be the easiest to beat.
And for the record, technically, you know, popular
vote, Hillary Clinton did beat him, but we didn't
go by popular vote. We go by Electoral College.
So that doesn't mean a whole heck of a lot.
The problem is these Democratic
groups are playing with fire.
The problem is the Democrats don't understand.
That the Republican Party doesn't
view these people as extremists.
They buy into the whole oh, no, they're just
an outsider. The swamp is coming after them
because they're out there draining it all.
They're the true fighters. They're the ones
out there spreading the truth and fighting for
us. They're saying the things the other folks
are too scared to say. That's how Republicans
view these people. That's why they get elected
into office in the first place. Yes, every
now and then, some of them are like, hey,
we were duped. We're not making that
mistake again. See also Madison Cawthorn.
But we had to have Madison Cawthorn in Congress
before the people who voted for him realized how
bad he was. And we could be looking at a similar
situation in these areas where the Democrats are
promoting the extremist candidates. It's a stupid
strategy. Let's be honest. Let's call it what it
is. It's stupid. It's something that hasn't worked
for the Democrats in the past. And of course,
it ignores the fact that most Republicans
actually like what these people have to say.
They support these policies. Only 21% of
Republicans in recent polling said they
believe Biden legitimately won the election,
only 20% of them. They believe the craziness.
So maybe the best strategy is not to promote
these people, but to remind the voters that these
extremists aren't living in a little place that
we like to call reality. We got to take another
quick break. Again, I'm Ferron Cousins. Find me
on YouTube at YouTube.com. Slash the ring of fire
and YouTube.com slash. Fair and balanced. I'm
on Twitter, Instagram and Facebook at Fair and
Balanced. Sitting in for David Pakman. We'll be
right back with more from The David Pakman Show.